[Musique]
guerres famines et maladies les trois
fléaux vi et mène depuis cinq ans le
pays est déchiré par un conflit
d'ampleur internationale principalement
d'un côté les rebelles chiites houthis à
l'ouest soutenue par l'iran de l'autre
les forces loyales au gouvernement
appuyés par une puissante coalition
internationale menée par l'arabie
saoudite
conséquence de cette guerre le yémen
fait face à une grave crise sanitaire a
commencé par la famine selon l'onu 2 4
millions d'enfants de moins de 5 ans
souffriraient de malnutrition
des milliers d'entre eux risquent la
mort à court ou moyen terme 20 millions
de personnes au total seraient concernés
par l'insécurité alimentaire
sans compter le manque d'accès à l'eau
potable ou au service d'hygiène
nous devons mobiliser les ressources
pour que l'aide humanitaire qui est
maintenant très inférieurs aux niveaux
nécessaires puissent être distribués à
une population dans une situation très
dramatique il sommes dans une situation
dramatique nous devons mettre fin au
conflit
nous devons nous assurer que nous
entrons dans un processus politique et
en même temps nous devons mobiliser des
ressources et créer les conditions
d'accès pour se tenir la population qui
se trouve dans une situation désespérée
le yémen doit désormais également
affronter la pandémie de kobe 19 et dans
ce combat contre le virus le pays et
mallarmé ici à sanaa les hôpitaux sont
dépassés en cause une économie et des
infrastructures en ruine
je ne veux pas penser au futur parce que
ce sera comme dans un cauchemar
j'essaie d'éviter de penser à la suite
parce que nous n'avons pas de médecin
officiellement on compte à peine plus de
2000 cas de contamination au saas cov de
dans le pays est moins 2 600 morts soit
un taux de mortalité 24 fois inférieur à
celui de la france et plus de six fois
inférieur à celui de l'arabie saoudite
voisine des chiffres probablement très
en deçà de la réalité
les capacités des tests du pays sont
très limités et les rebelles houthi ont
cessé de publier
statistiques relatives aux zones qu'ils
contrôlent quant aux yéménites ils sont
nombreux à ne tout simplement pas croire
à la maladie ou pensent s'en prémunir en
mâchant le khat une plante locale aux
effets psychotropes
il n'y a pas de coronavirus au yémen il
n'y a pas de corps au nahd du tout des
gens mentent ce sont des menteurs
quand vous avez de la fièvre de la
fatigue mâcher du khat et vous vous
sentez mieux
et malgré cette situation la guerre qui
ravage le yémen ne laisse pour le moment
entrevoir aucune issue une guerre dont
le bilan s'élève déjà à plus de cent
mille victimes